hello kashish thank you for introducing
yourself
yes we are excited to hear from you
about your project we are just waiting
for rest of the participants to join the
program and
join the webinar so we are just waiting
in the meantime i switch you can
introduce yourself like your educational
background your research interest
so that we can know
yeah good evening everyone so uh
ma'am you want me to uh write it in the
chat or should i just say it out loud
you can introduce yourself during the
research project presentation
okay
thank you
so for the participants who have
recently joined please feel free to
introduce yourself in the chat box you
can mention your education background
your research interest
we are just waiting for uh rest of the
participants to join the meeting
so yes
all right so let's start today's webinar
in the meantime for the participants who
have recently joined please feel free to
introduce yourself in the chat box
like your educational background
and without further delay let's start
with today's webinar
so
hello everyone a very warm greeting to
one and all my name is shree gary
krsnagmar and i would like to invite you
all to today's webinar on omixlogic
a research fellowship program uh so to
give you a brief overview of the program
it is designed to help young students
and researchers to take advantage of the
bioinformatic resources for the analysis
of complex life science data and become
well-versed in bioinformatics and the
research fellows participate in
cutting-edge bioinformatics research led
by expert mentors during the course of
the program
and the fellowship program will offer a
combination of online resources and
mentor guidance to prepare you and help
you complete a bioinformatics project
the registration fees will cover the
cost of training mentorship and big data
tool that is t bioinfo
server the platform is a cloud-based
analytic at analytical server used by
research labs and independent scientists
around the world so to briefly give you
an overview of today's agenda first we
will have the student presentations
followed by which we will have the
mental feedback for the projects
and then finally we will take you
through the registration process behind
the research valuation program
and before we begin let me introduce you
to the team behind the program
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy-to-use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
the omics logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that help us refine the
local logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
the omixlogic program follows a
project-based learning approach using
research grade tools to analyze data
from top peer-reviewed journals and the
omics logic
has a six different specialization
tracks which includes oncology
infectious diseases precision medicine
neuroscience data science for biomedical
data and comprehensive training on omix
data analysis
and as a result we have acquired
professional certification to offer our
curriculum and support research project
using our omixologic project-based
calculator
together with our existing modules for
which you will gain access to the omics
logic portal where you can try and
explore these modules exercises in
pipeline building coding and various
methods of analysis using project
sources from peer-reviewed publications
and today we will take you through the
research projects and help you get
started with your journey in research
fellowship program so first of all
let me let's sign up on the portal
on the omislogic learn portal so i'll
share the link to the portal in the chat
box
all right so
i'll pause for a moment so once everyone
has
um visited the website please put a yes
so that
i can proceed further
okay so
so to begin with click on the tab that
says login
so once you click on the login tab
either you will be asked to sign in so
if you already have signed up on the
portal you don't have to sign up again
otherwise if you're new to the portal
click on the create an account option
and this will ask you to give your name
your email id and your password so you
can enter your name and or you also have
the option to log in using the google
account facebook account apple account
or github and even twitter
so
i'll wait for a moment so that
the participants can log in to the
portal
and once you have created an account
please put a yes
so that i know i can proceed further
and if you have any queries you can put
it in the chat box
and i can help you with that
um
all right so
does anyone have any queries about
logging in or creating an account
so you can please put it in the chat box
so i'm proceeding further
so since i already have an account
created i'm going to use a login option
and once you sign in
you will be taken to
this page
so before we go further i want you to
click on the tab that says welcome pack
and this will take you to your account
basic account
and here it is important because in this
part you need to first update your
account with a proper name
your link to your social media handles
and a brief buy about yourself so how do
you go about doing that you click on the
tab that says profile
and here you have the option to add your
bio your profile image your name
link to your social media handles so in
my case i have linked my linkedin
profile and my arc id profile
and once you have updated click on
update
and there you go you'll have an updated
profile and this is important because
this will help the researchers and
students in the community to connect
with you better
so and if you come here you will see
under the tab that says activity it will
show you
what is the current progress in your
learning process and this is where the
mentor will check your learning
activities so that we can figure out if
you're stuck in any course or if you are
facing any technical challenges
and if you wish to explore uh
and if you're doing any particular
course that will appear under this
course step so currently i'm doing uh
project 17 tuberculosis infection and
treatment it is really interesting
projects so if someone is interested in
genomics please check it out it's a
really interesting product so if you are
interested to uh check any other courses
you can go to the courses tab and type
in your keywords that you're interested
to explore and under the projects tab
you will see all the student projects
that you can go through
so
now i would like to invite um we have
the much awaited presentations by the
students so up first i would like to
invite uh kashish he will be uh
explaining his project so over to you
guys
uh thank you ma'am
can you please give me the access for
presenting the screen
yes
hi everyone myself
and i'm a student of amity university
and
currently i'm pursuing my msc
bioinformatics from the college
and my research work is on in-silicon
analysis of transcriptional responses
to uv and ionization ionizing radiations
in skin cells
now uh
this data i selected this database
because i was interested in knowing how
the sun rays can affect our skin cells
and what all changes they make at uh in
our body at molecular level
the introduction slide uh just gives us
the brief uh how
the this dna response pathways that
are
affected
can be studied
these pathways include cell cycling and
cell cycling proliferation a dna repair
mechanism and stress response mechanisms
the methodology adopted uh in my data
set which i have taken my data set was
gac 1977.
here the microarray data was used and in
this data
there were a genome wide portraits were
made for
from
15 individuals into 10 000 cell lines
these cell lines were
then projected to
uv and ionization radiation
treatment so once the result was taken
out the distribution was made into three
different samples
namely mock ir and uv
the pipeline that i used was uh this
slide shows the pipeline
we went through a drug
data identification grouping and merging
the data along with the
by merging i meant merging the
probabilities with the gene ids
then some statistical analysis and
finally pathway analysis
in data identification the data was
taken from ncbi geo dataset
here uh
i as i just told data set was gac 1977
on which is on skin cancer
the grouping was made the uh first what
i did was i
downloaded the series matrix to raw
series matrix table
once that was downloaded i
filtered out the data which was
necessary that is
interested data and i classified into
into these three
groups
later on i performed pc analysis and for
pc analysis i use t by infoserver t by
info server provides us as uh works as a
single platform and offers us many
pipelines to
run our analysis i have the pictorial
representation of everything that i'm
saying right now
in path analysis
we basically
i went through links and panther
databases links pathways library of
integrated network-based cellular
signatures in cellular signatures we are
actually taking the gene ids along with
the log 4 change values
and p value is optional in it
then
i also used panther that is protein
analysis through evolutionary
relationships
links pathway
is like an umbrella which has many
different uh
pathway analysis tools within it
and
it has the
directing links for ev
for those pathways for example you can
go to pinet
reactome
or
david
and richard many are there
the main difference between using lynx
and panther is panther gives us the
evolutionary relation
additionally gives the evolutionary
relationships between the genes which is
not offered by links directly
this was the dataset this was the raw
dataset i chose the uh the data set and
then i grouped them into this
red data set represents the
uh ir data set and
green ones are the mock and this is the
uv data set
in merging process what i did is uh the
microarray data that we have obtained
from our series matrix table it contains
the probe ids but we need the gene ids
for our further analysis to know what
all genes are present and how
and then only we can move forward for
our pathway analysis in it so i chose
david in from david i
as an input i gave the
probe ids to the
this database and once the probe ids
were given and some uh parameters were
selected i
got i get an output of this gene id is
here along with the gene names and the
species from which they are they belong
using our code i merge these two data
data sets
yeah this is the t by
platform home page you can see there are
many uh
different specified
pipelines that this single platform
offers and you can go through all these
pipelines according to your need
you can also you can go for a super
supervised analysis unsupervised
analysis both these have pcas in it and
there are many uh rna-seq analysis also
there along with a biology and
specifically special cancer biology
analysis
are also there
now this is the pca
pipeline which i used in the
in my research and this is uh the result
i got before grouping my data sets
and this is the result i got after
grouping so after grouping i ran three
different uh pcas
on which was against mock
versus
ir and uv
uv and ir separately
now uh from this result i
have not much no
i mean i was not able to form a pipeline
for my further analysis because this uh
you can see the plot is still too much
scattered and there's no much similarity
which can i which i can draw from this
so
i kept it uh as it is for uh
now and then i move further
using links
using links i submitted the signatures
uh signatures and once the signature was
submit submitted these were the pathways
that were given and these pathways
helped me uh in
further you
going through my pathway analysis
enricher offers us with
further different redirecting links of
keg and many humans csc 2016 and this is
the representation of
2021 that is shown and
um
this is the cluster gram representation
of the this expression
which was given these are the genes
which are there and these are the
pathways that
were involved in my analysis
in panther db the input is different
from links here we use the input as
comma separated gene ids
once the comma separated gene ids are
recorded in in the in this
box and some parameter changes are made
we can get the result in a uh tabular
form
graphical form or in a statistical
enrichment uh test
method so in graphical representation
this
representation is between ir and mock
and this gives us the expression level
of the various genes
of uh which are included in these
pathways
this is for uv and mock
now i'll go directly to the result
now
in the result
uh i saw that there uh
down regulation of gene was uh more as
compared to the upregulated pathways and
majority of the genes that were involved
in uv response were miscellaneous that
is there was not a significant study
that uh have been performed on these
genes
but out of uh now you can see uh i have
a short period of time of four months so
uh two months were devoted for training
and the other two months were for my
research work so what i'd for a faster
analysis what i did is i gave i gave a
threshold of nine
genes here to get the uh
pathways here and i selected only these
few pathways for my analysis
and the result that was
uh
drawn out was that the these were the
genes it atp
atf
mapk and there are many other genes so
that was given these were the main uh
peak genes that were responsive to ir
and uv
now the interpretation that that
i made that
there was an abrupt activity in the cell
cycle
energy metabolism which
led to development of
induced skin lesions due to ir and uv
there was also a disruption in apoptotic
pathway which can be inferred
like uh that the immune activity is
uh i mean there is an uh immune activity
is boosted to tackle the lesion
development or there is a breakdown in
the essential cellular components uh
that are aiding in prevention of further
problem proliferation
these are the reference
major references that i use this is the
major uh research paper from which i
extracted my data set and uh
this is the uh t by infoserver reference
i have given
and
pathway
panther
databases and there were many other
references but these were the main
references which were
more focused on
thank you
all right thank you so much kasha this
was really informative and before we
move on to the next participle i do have
a query for you that is one is what was
your overall program experience and
secondly you completed this project
within a span of two months but which is
kind of short so do you have any tips
and tricks for the interested
participants who wish to ace a project
like you did
uh yeah what i did is while i was going
through my uh two-month program to my
training program i
uh when after one month i started
looking for my data data set of interest
which
made my research faster
so
if i have my data set
in hand before i actually start
researching about my analysis and
instead of waiting for two months to
have my data set i
just started it i started looking for it
uh beforehand
so it saved around 15 to 20 days for
my of my time
and
about the experience it was a very good
experience
and
uh
i have a very i had a very nice
experience with
my faculty and my mentors here
and they were they are quite friendly
and they helped me to gain
quite a good amount of information quite
a good amount of exposure in a very
short period of time
and i hope to learn further from them
thank you
all right thank you so much prashish now
let's wait for um expert feedback from
dr raghav before that uh let's move on
to the next participant that is sanskrit
shukla so she will be presenting her
research project so over to you sanskrit
hello everyone
so
[Music]
my topic of interest
has been cancer biology and immunology
so
the research topic that i chose
so my topic was analysis of variance in
the genomic landscape in the context of
cancer immunotherapy
and uh
so with this project
there were two main questions
there were
two main things that i aim to
do and the first was to understand what
are the alternate therapeutic options
available for
uh lung cancer a specific type of lung
cancer that is non-small cell lung
cancer and the second was to analyze
gene expression in patients who are
patients who are being administered with
immune checkpoint inhibitors that is a
form of immunotherapy and alternative
therapy for uh cancer
and how that how it could be used in the
duration of therapy
so
for a little bit of introduction my area
of focus was uh non-small side lung
cancer and
non-small cell lung cancer forms about
80 percent of the diagnosed cancer cases
and about 90 percent of the cancer
that's uh caused by lung cancer are
caused by non-sponsored lung cancer so
the study in this area is uh very
important and
despite having established therapeutic
options like surgical resection
radiotherapy and chemotherapy we still
see about one
point million cancer deaths due to this
uh hence
there is a
there's a need to analyze other
alternative forms of
cancer therapy
so immune
is an answer to this immunotherapy is
basically using
your body's own immune system to
fight cancer
uh i'm going to be focusing more on
immune checkpoint inhibitors so to do
this we need to understand what immune
checkpoints are
and uh immune checkpoints uh
consist of receptors like uh
pd1 and ctla4 and these are expressed by
almost all types of t t-cells across
time and magnitude of
the immune response so as immune
response increases in body the the
such receptors the
number of such receptors on the surface
of t-cell also increases
uh in normal conditions these would
interact with the ligands on dendritic
cells and other
other cells of the body and suppress the
immune response so that there's no
damage to the
to the patient cells
uh and this forms the basis of
autoimmune autoimmune based prevention
which is essential but cancer cells take
advantage of this and also express uh
the ligands pdl1 and d7 and are thus
able to mute the immune response caused
by the body against cancer cells
and the interaction between these uh
this receptor and ligand combination
sets off
such of a molecular cascade and this
molecular cascade uh dampens effector t
cell response that is uh it reduces the
number of active hepatitis and uh
kilodiesels in the tumor micro
environment so
uh
and it also increases the number of
regulatory t cells in the micro
environment so together this forms a
micro environment that is uh that has
very high levels of pro-inflammatory
cytokines
uh
so the result is
very aggressive tumor growth which uh
and uh
immune suppression in in such patients
so what immune checkpoint inhibitors do
is they actually they
they interfere between this interaction
between the
receptors in the ligands and prevent
this
suppression of immune system in cancer
in cancer cells
so for my uh project i focused on
nivolumab nibolumab targets a specific
immune checkpoint that is pd1 and it is
a humanized antibody
so
when patients are administered with pd1
the pd1 reaches the tumor micro
environment and interferes with the
response and slowly
[Music]
theoretically
our effector t cell numbers are supposed
to increase
the cytokine overload is supposed to
decrease and regulate the cells are
supposed to disperse from the tumor
microbiome
so for this
so
my
project
aims to answer two important questions
and uh the first is can genes expressed
in uh human infiltrating cd8 t cells
influence response to ica therapy which
is immune checkpoint inhibition and this
is important because although uh the
immune
this is a theoretically very robust uh
technology but uh we
see that it fails in a certain
certain cohort of patients so we want to
find out if we want to find out if we
can somehow predict which which patients
would respond to this therapy and we
could
uh
administer the drug to only those
patients
so
and if transcriptomic profiling is the
answer to this question and the second
question is are genes expressed in uh
the tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
affected by nibolumabs so this can help
us in tracking how the therapy is
progressing and if it's causing any
changes to the tumor or not
so i
shortlisted my
data set and this
this is a data set of
10 patients so i had
20
20 samples and
the
transcriptomic data from before the
administration of the drug and after the
administration of drug was available on
uh jio
and this is what i used for
my
for the analysis
so
all of the analysis that
i performed was performed on t bioinfo
platform
as uh kashish mentioned there are uh
many different kinds of pipelines
available that you could use depending
on depending on what kind of analysis
that you want to perform so in my case
it was transcriptomic data
so
uh
i had to run some initial preprocessing
steps where alignment and mapping
which was performed by the rnac pipeline
uh using algorithms like about e2t and
arson expression table
and after i filtered out some genes with
very low crowns or very high counts i
moved on to the
trucks of the this analysis so there
were two different kinds of analysis
that i performed the first was
exploratory analysis and the second was
differential gene expression analysis
so
i'll be discussing the results of my
analysis
the first is exploratory analysis which
was
conducted using tca
so what pca does is it maximizes the
variance
the variation between the
values that we have
and we are basically aiming to find if
the variation with the maximize
variation corresponds with the groups
that we have in our data
the groups that are represented here so
but as
i perform 2d analysis as well but the 2d
graph did not show much separation so i
had to move on to a 3d plot and this is
the 3d plot that separates all the
groups that are present in my data
as you can see
the groups don't cluster
the groups don't cluster according to
their uh colors and
uh the only clustering somewhat uh
clustering is seen in non-responders
after the administration of uh
the drug that has nevolumab and it's not
very useful to us
uh i perform more pc analysis using the
data for different groups
but i'd like to draw your attention
towards this
separation that is observed in all these
graphs right down the middle we'll
discuss how
it would what it would mean in a bit
uh after accelerating analysis i perform
the differential gene expression
analysis so this would show us what kind
of genes what genes are upregulated or
downregulated at uh different time
points or between different groups and
this would help us see how
influence uh regulation and gene
regulation or gene expression in
patients so the first differential gene
expression analysis was between the
responders and non-responders before the
administration of nivolumab
and uh
as this is a volcano plot and the y-axis
uh shows a negative log based on of the
adjusted value so
if you're aware about p adjusted values
uh they form a statistical threshold of
how significant our uh
analysis is
and
uh usually for bio uh for biological
experiments appear just a value of 0.05
or even 0.01 is considered as a good
value
but
for my analysis the lowest p adjusted
value was 0.13 so
for this particular question
whether we have predictors whether we
have predictors that we could use
to see which patients would respond to
negotiable
we can see that there are not many genes
that are
differentially upregulated or down
regulated significantly up regulated or
down regulated in the
group
but
so this was the next differential gene
expression analysis and this was
between
the responders at time time point n1 and
n2 which is before and after the
administration of nebuloma
so
this
is a very this is a significant analysis
because um
it would help us it would help us
track how the therapy is progressing and
the graph also shows some promising
results we have three specific genes
that showed uh down regulation
and uh had
pretty good pre-adjusted values
and uh
however the one thing that needs to be
noted is these genes are mostly
all of these genes are not
non-coding rna
but non-coding rna even if they don't
produce any protein products they are
heavily involved and they're heavily
involved in how
protein coding genes work and
how
biomolecular pathways proceed in our
body
and uh performing some
uh preliminary literature review on
these genes that i obtained i found out
that he's been for very significant
these genes have some significance in
cancer biology and immunology as a whole
so the first gene is heavily involved in
the wnt pathway and i won't go much into
the details of how it has evolved but
overall it improves uh the effector t
cells that are dampened in a tumor micro
environment and improves t-cell function
basically so we have more cytotoxic
reasons
to target uh
to target the tumor cells in our body
and uh the other
one other gene the tma d7 uh tcam ii
non-coding gene so it is also involved
in uh tran trif pathway which produces
pro-inflammatory cytokines so a down
regulation in these genes means that uh
our thesis there is better t-cell
activation and less cytokine overload in
the uh tumor micro environment which
uh which shows us that these genes uh
these genes have uh some significance in
uh significance in answering our
question if we could uh use
transcriptomic compiling
to
track how therapy progresses
and um
so to summarize how to summarize what
we've seen the pca results show us that
there is
some kind of confounding variable or
some that is not available with the data
that i obtained from jio
and more
a deeper analysis needs to be performed
on that because there is definitely
separation in the data
and for
the differential gene expression
analysis i found that although we don't
have although the from the data set i
couldn't find any genes that could act
as predictors but i
we do have biomarkers that could
biomarkers that could uh target that
could help us in uh seeing how the tumor
is evolving throughout the course of the
therapy and this this becomes
significant because when we think about
how tumors are generally analyzed the
methods are very invasive you either
get biopsies or
you need
screening screening by multiple
imaging techniques
but if we use
genes that are genes that are expressed
in killer t cells we could just uh take
a blood sample and extract killer t
cells or
extract killer cells by uh
facis and then we could
we could uh use transcriptomic profiling
for that it is less invasive for the
patients so i think
this is a good step towards that
direction
and uh
so in conclusion
uh after literature review and after the
analysis i
found that
although nivolumab in itself does not
give very promising results but if we
combine it with other immune checkpoint
inhibitors it would give better results
and that means that that means that
the results or the way patients react to
this
drug or this type of is uh
solely dependent on how genes are
expressed
all right thank you so much sanskritas
so um i do have uh two queries for you
so first of all
there might be participants after
listening to your presentation they
might be wondering i don't have much
knowledge
or
skills to perform a project like you did
but obviously you did undergo a lot of
training and a lot of course completion
and example projects so could you please
explain
what where the preparations that you
went through to complete your project
like were there any courses or example
projects that helped you or you liked
better or like that inspired you
uh okay so
yeah
uh
the topic that i had because i was
working on transcriptomic profiling so i
work
i finished the transcriptomics course
that is available on mixlogic platform
and most of the analysis that i
performed even troubleshooting
sometimes my pipelines wouldn't work all
that is mentioned in the
course outline in the course content and
even if you get stuck somewhere the
mentors are always there to help you
throughout the week
and
there are some example projects as you
mentioned
so because i was working on cancer
biology and
cancer biology and immunotherapy the
there are
uh
i referred to three or four projects on
that is those are present on the omex
logic platform one of them i think
targets
how uh
how
transcriptomic genomic profiling is used
in breast cancer studies
and i think there is one for liver
cancer uh liver cancer analysis so all
these
this course and the projects together
helped me in
building
my project
wonderful so uh the last query that i
have for you is so participants enroll
for the program they complete your pro
they complete the project and then
they're stuck they don't know how to
proceed further so how do you plan on
taking your project to the next level
so
i performed this project as a part of my
as a part of my course degree completion
but
from what i've learned
through the four months i think
the project that i uploaded on the
portal i can share it on multiple
platforms and i can also add it to my cv
so not only did it help me in the
completion of my degree but uh now i can
show it show it to my potential
employers or universities that i'll
apply to
and
other than that
right so some participants do have plans
to like present their project during
symposiums or participate in competition
or um you know even publish get their
project published so do you have any
such plans
yeah i actually do want to get my
project published and although my
project is over i'm still in contact
with my mentors and they're like
actively
helping me in
moulding this project into something
that i could publish
so
yeah i'm hoping to publish this very
soon
all right thank you so much sanskrita
all the best so now i'd like to pass on
the stage to dr raga he is the mentor
for the program so he'll be providing
the uh feedback for the two student
projects that we saw right now so over
to your doctor radha
thank you very much
and thank you very much
that was very informative very detailed
and very nicely presented projects from
both of you and i you would have heard
from me a lot about this project and
and about your study
and how your work also so i want to
congratulate to both of you that you did
a wonderful job and you also secured
good
grades from your universities uh for
which this project is done as a part of
requirement i want to mention that in
this forum as well and uh
for the feedback aspects
[Music]
mentor being mentor i just want to
mention to cassius you could include
little bit more results part in your
slides and and
and and then follow it up with the
detailed description and the
interpretation of what you did so that
was very nice
of extremely
high level detail in in your project and
your presentation passage that's very
nicely done
and uh
for sanskrit it's um very nice uh again
i like the way you structured your
presentation uh the both the visual
aspect and also uh the structure of the
presentation aspect you are very clear
on what is a question that you want to
answer and you are very
it was very nice to go back to those
questions and to check whether have we
answered these questions after the
after the analysis part and et cetera
and and
um i like that aspect from you and and
very nicely rounded up presentation from
you and and kashish also went into lot
of detail on
what you have learned from uh
from the data that suggests you are from
the data that actually it told you or
from the analysis that you performed so
i i liked
both of you your conclusion part so it
uh the scope of the
project actually went well beyond what
we were aiming for and we
and both of you found some really
interesting points which could
so or which could
uh which could be the seed to much
greater research effect in in these
subtopics right in in melanoma cancer
and also in
in the involvement of cd8 t cells in
cancer checkpoint immunotherapy so
very nice from both of you and thank you
for your time and thank you for your
presentations here thank you
thank you so much dr raga so next we
will hear from harini bala subramanian
on her research project
yes
hello everyone my name is harini
balasramanian and i'm a research fellow
at pine biotech today i will be
presenting my project titled in silico
comparative transcriptomic analysis of
endemic and epidemic kubose sarcoma
this project was mentored by dr
raghavendran lakshmi narayani
before i begin into
the details about my project i would
like to tell you a little bit about
myself
so
my uh
i have a bachelor's degree in industrial
biotechnology from anna university india
my research interests predominantly lie
in
molecular biology
so some example areas are micro rna
profile analysis toxicogenomics
precision medicine cancer biology and
methylation epigenetics
i aspired to pursue my master's degree
in molecular and cellular biology
so
what is capocity sarcoma
kaposi sarcoma is an anti-proliferative
multicentric malignancy that is
triggered by the infection of kshv or
kaposi sarcoma associated herpes virus
it has four distinct clinical subtypes
first epidemic ks which is an aggressive
subtype that is commonly occurring in
hiv zero positive individuals second
the classic chaos which is found in
older men of eastern european descent
third endemic yes which is prevalent in
certain areas of equatorial or
sub-saharan africa
and lastly
transplant related ks which occurs when
an immunosuppressed transplant patient
is also infected with kshp
so kshv is an oncogenic human gamma
herpes virus
which is also the etiological agent that
is responsible for not only kaposi
sarcoma but also strongly associated
with b cell proliferative disorders
including primary effusion lymphoma
the variant binds to the cell surface
receptor following which the viral dna
migrates into the nucleus
kshv exists between a lytic and latent
life cycle upon infection kshv
establishes a long-term persistent
infection in humans where it manipulates
multiple host signaling pathways and
also modulates the expression of
cellular genes to thrive in the infected
cells
in general kshv infection is essential
but not adequate to induce ks disease
progression despite antiretroviral
treatment the prognosis for ks is often
poor with high mortality due to the
presentation of late cancer stage
therefore
to identify more accurate detection
methods and therapeutic targets against
ks a better understanding of the viral
and trans and cellular transcriptomes in
the cancer are necessary
so
[Music]
this is the information about the data
set that i obtained for my analysis
the data was downloaded from the nc ncbi
geo platform in raw rate counts
the study involved a total of 51 samples
of which three samples of normal skin
were taken from three healthy
individuals and the rest from ks
patients
here the samples from the diseased
individuals were obtained in pairs that
is the biopsies from lesional skin and
uninvolved sites on the same individual
were collected
raw cons for each chain from the human
and kshv transcriptomes were provided by
the authors
this is the methodology and the
flowchart that i followed for the for my
analysis
firstly i group the samples into endemic
care samples epidemic and normal skin
secondly
exploratory analysis or principal
component analysis here was conducted
using the following parameters
pca was conducted first for all the
samples and then for endemic and
epidemic separately
next differential expression analysis
using the desector algorithm and the
enrichment and gse modules were also
performed uh to understand the
upregulated and downregulated genes
and these were the parameters that were
used for the analysis
and lastly human gage analysis for a
better understanding of the pathways was
also performed using the parameters as
given on the flow chart
these are the results of the pca
pipeline
and
this is the result for the
differential expression and human gene
uh human gauge results so
um for epidemic ks and endemic ks
dot cloths for uh geoen rich pathways uh
cnet plots also for enriched pathways
volcano plots uh they were all obtained
and uh for epidemic years alone the
arachidonic acid pathway and retinol
metabolism were significantly
downregulated
along with cemip
were found to be massively upregulated
so ppef1
is significantly correlated with retinal
degeneration and
pcdh17 and cemip were found to uh have
positive
correlations with cell to cell
connection and epithelial mesenchymal
transition pathways
so the over expression of these genes in
epidemic case patients is indicative of
sarcoma progression
next let's look at the uh volcano plot
for endemic ks
so first
if we see the uh
s100a1 gene uh it plays a an important
role in inhibition of microtubule
assembly so its increased construction
level can be implicated in promoting
cell proliferation and migration like
the pc
sk6 gene and thereby the metastasis of
cancer cancer tissues
uh
moving on to the pathways
the lipid metabolism and energy in the
energy generation pathways uh were
significantly down regulated in epidemic
years
the lack of regulation in lipid
metabolism was observed in both uh
subtypes
but uh the transcriptional imbalance was
more pronounced in epidemic yes
and this can be seen in the arachidonic
acid pathway as i mentioned earlier
the arachidonic acid is a multifaceted
pufa molecule that confers cell
permeability uh that converts
permeability to the cell membrane and
also uh produces uh is also involved in
producing prostaglandins and
leukotrienes
in conclusion
um
six genes in endemic years and epidemic
yes were identified respectively to be
differentially expressed in these
disease conditions
while the incidence of endemic ks is
decreasing in developed countries like
the usa it is still very prevalent in
sub-saharan africa and the mediterranean
so
till date the detection of lana or
the orf1 gene product is the golden
standard for kshv diagnostics in this
study too orf73 uh gene uh which encodes
for lana
was found to be well upregulated in both
conditions with similar fall change
values
but how far a lana-based assay can
characterize the extent of case
progression is not clear
so from our from this study uh two two
potential biomarkers have been
identified one orf6 and two sox11
uh orf6 uh could be a potential
biomarker for detecting co-infection in
kshv in hiv-positive individuals
and sox-11 since it's heavily involved
in propagating lesions and triggering
angiogenesis makes it another
prospective biomarker for ks
so in conclusion
more research on the physiological and
genotypic presentation of capocity
sarcoma is highly essential uh to
discover more therapeutic targets um
that can increase not only the longevity
but also the quality of life in people
living with hiv and in case patients
these are the references that i used
uh thank you so much
all right so next i would like to invite
dr raghav to go over the research topics
for the research fellowship program
thank you siri gallery i think we have a
question in the chat box and sonia
khadian asks how did you make the
volcano plot dot plot and pca plot using
r or any online software so you
obviously can use r but as students and
as participants mentioned most of these
plots that they obtained are from direct
outputs and direct results from the from
running the pipeline in the tbio info
server platform
in the back end the platform uses are
a combination of our other and other
coding languages to produce and generate
these uh output files so um
but you can effectively use r to
produces also so um for these analysis
all of these results are used uh
generated from the pipeline or from um
analyzing the results and data assets
through the pipeline training pre-bio
info platform
and more information on that uh
will be provided by sri gauri's
navigator okay
let's let me find ways to share my
screen so that i can introduce you to
the
program and the topics and what are we
going to discuss in research
uh topics right research programming
topics
you can access this specific page from
this website or from this web link
and let's
yeah
can trigger please confirm uh that i you
can see my screen
that reads the research
yeah does it read research topics for
our mixed logic am i sharing with saying
okay perfect
so this is a consolidated uh
web page for what the research
topics and what the research fellowship
inter program is all about
so when we go down i think you would
have gotten a lot of introduction about
uh
how different students and researchers
can make use of big data while
performing different analysis and what
do i mean by that let's go down you will
get
these
specific advantages of um
when you sign up for the research
fellowship program so you have
curriculum that specifically designed
for the for your research area and for
your research interests and you have
your own self-paced learning and
most of the courses and most of the
resources that we are going to share
with you in the research fellowship
program is asynchronous meaning you will
learn at your pace you will do this at
your pace and then
we will be there to discuss with you
about your progress and
about how to proceed further in the
research fellowship program and you will
get hands-on with big data as expertly
demonstrated by three students
research topics so all of them
obtain data from publicly available
forum and all of these data are big data
big omics data and they used this big
comics data to address different parts
of the biological uh queries and
questions and you will have access to
expert mentors like myself like dr mohit
and others so when you start learning
you will get uh
immediate feedback from us and we are
accessible to you
offline and also uh we we will meet you
once or twice during the week
during the scheduled
research fellowship meeting and also if
you request for one-on-one meeting for
some specific cases then we will offer
that also
so when you go down what are the
different areas in which the omics data
and multi-omics data in general are
being used to address specific research
questions you have a variety of topics
that uses omics data as of now which
will include genomics data
transcriptomics data epigenomics
metagenomics and these are only few that
we are getting or that we are actually
focusing on you have
furthermore you have proteomics you have
metabolomics and etc a lot of other
omics data types are coming up in trying
to address different areas of biological
research so and
we have actually this site this web link
gives you one of the some of the major
applications of our mix data analysis to
different areas of analysis that is
described that is focused so some of the
obvious focuses on infectious diseases
and the pandemic era that we are
currently living is is a perfect example
for what omics data can achieve in
in addressing infectious diseases case
and we all
know uh different terminologies related
to stars like variance of concern
variance of interest how does it spread
like
what are the different lineages right
and
what are the mutations that actually
characterize variance of concern these
variants of interest and all of these
analysis are direct results from
genomics data and transcriptomics data
analysis
so when you use the whole genome
sequence of the virus and try to compare
it with the
other strains and other variants of this
same virus you will get lot of
information and this is just one example
of what you can achieve from
from the from sequencing the whole
genome sequence of the virus and
similarly this can be extended to a
transcript of landscape analysis which
will characterize how a patient is going
to respond to the onset of the disease
or to some
drugs that is going to fight against the
progression of this disease and these
are just two omics data types that is
trying to provide us with lot of
information in addressing some of the
key questions in infectious diseases and
we can again do this in meta genomics
data analysis and epigenomics data
analysis which are also extremely
important omics data type that are
coming up and i would like to stress the
importance of meta genomics data
analysis where the gut microbiome or the
microbiome um
estimation of the human gut is being
linked to various other disease onsets
like cancer like allergy like even a
neurological disorders and pathological
states so so that
that level of uh association is
is been
exploration of that level of association
is being carried out at various
different uh labs and and this is one of
the
interesting and upcoming omics data
types analysis methods and the questions
that we can answer through uh analyzing
and observing patterns within the
metagenomics data so when you go down we
have lot of project examples on omix
learn which focuses on different omics
data analysis in trying to address key
questions in infectious diseases like
sars like malarial infection like um the
sf9 cells will actually uh tell you
about how to uh
identify viral contamination in your
samples and ebola virus epidemic is an
excellent example of how genomics data
was used to
track the progression this disease
progression and spread of ebola virus so
when you come down the application of
our mix data analysis is at its peak to
oncology because of the requirement and
because of how a mixed data
characterizes tumor cancer and
generally the disease progression and
its effect on various types of patients
and various types of
yeah
on various types of races and admission
so what we get
part of the reason why it is required
because of the existing traditional
methods of identifying characterizing
understanding the disease progression of
tumor and treating the disease tumor
disease and cancer as such is not
sufficiently effective so hence we had
to research to transcriptomics or
genomics data analysis epigenomics data
analysis and etcetera so when we have a
wealthy of such information and big data
it is natural that
methods that are specifically designed
to analyze patterns from these large
quantities of data like advanced
statistical methods involving artificial
intelligence deep learning machine
learning will come in handy so they are
also at its most useful when you are
trying to use a large volume of data
like transcriptomics data from major
from lot of patients as compiled in a
wonderful public repository like the
cancer genome atlas or tcga so we also
have a
ncbi database where the sra data will
provide you lot of genomics information
and genomics data where you can focus on
for example
genome-wide association studies targeted
loci studies to understand the
specific genes and driver genes that are
that could be used to
answer and that could be used to explore
the onset disease progression and the
treatment response of different tumor
from different cases
there are also efforts in understanding
cancer from integrating multiple or
multi-orgs
as such from maximizing the information
and also integrating the omics data type
with a wealthy of cancer history patient
history database and test patient
history data and and the treatment
information data and genetic data
genetic history data generally that
most of the
translational approaches will acquire at
the time of diagnosis and we are we can
also use traditional methods like using
structural biology and uh omix data uh
in omix data integrated into structural
biology
for
developing different drug targets and
drug molecules like chemo informatics
data to
to to approach the translational
problems of finding and identifying
targets for
for these cancer research and also
finding and
developing
treatment strategies for targeting these
specific
targets that we identify from structural
biology efforts
as i mentioned in the previous case
metagenomics has been is one of the
upcoming area that has been
linked to majority of the onset and
progression of disease from various
other parts of our body and this doesn't
stop but cancer and this doesn't stop at
gut
or
chronic diseases development so again uh
to give you a few examples of what are
the different projects that we have in
omix omix learn we have a
project that focuses mainly on the
immune
response of the cancer to different
immune therapies and we have
projects that deals with mass or huge
volume of data from the cancer genome
atlas to identify risk factors that are
associated with the liver cancer and we
have
we have a project that actually tries to
relate omics data with the treatment
response data that is observed from
crafting the tumor into model
environment like mouse model and like
cell line models etc
and that will straight away form and
that will straight away lead us from
understanding oncology through mix data
analysis into
translational aspects of oncology in
precision medicine through the
application of omics data analysis in
in treating cancer so for this specific
for this specific aspect or for this
specific um
research
research topic then we have one project
or we have multiple other
examples with this specific project
modeling cancer precision medicine which
i was talking about where the cancer
cells were grown in a cell line data
cell line in
where they are grown in cell line
environment and they were treated with
multitude of different treatments and
their response to different treatments
through
through the
through increase or decrease in the
volume of the tumors are observed and
this response treatment response is
directly linked with multiple omics that
characterizes these
tumor cells and by
linking these omics data type and a
treatment response we can identify which
treatments are effective and how we can
use our mix data types to effectively or
to
accurately identify the effectiveness of
this treatment and this will fall
straight into patient stratification in
terms of which patients are what are the
subset of patients that will respond to
a specific treatment and treatment
strategy stratification in terms of what
are the possible treatment options that
i can suggest to a
patient who is likely to respond to
several different treatment options and
this doesn't stop at treating hosts from
host from
human or from
[Music]
majority
focus on homo sapiens and human this
also
extends to agriculture where i believe
the
analysis has lots to offer and the
application has lot to offer in terms of
understanding for example
drought resistance understanding for
example salinity resistance
understanding for example heat
resistance of crops which naturally have
are quite these characteristics since
they are being
since they are being exposed to these
harsh conditions one can one can
characterize the these plants um using
again these molecular characterization
methods from omics data types analysis
and then try to apply whether such
whether bringing about such changes in a
different plant can actually result in
developing resistance for drought
developing salinity in the resistance
and also
whether can we transfer the ability of
plants to
survive in harsh condition
by changing the omics
landscape of these plants so such
efforts are actually actively going on
in
in agricultural area and again to stress
on the application of metagenomics data
analysis to a wide variety of biology
and in general people usually take the
soil samples understand the microbiome
population of the soil samples from
different parts like from for example
from
from a region which receives very low
rainfall or from a region which receives
very high rainfall so we can understand
what are the different
bacteria fungi and virus that makes use
of these conditions and effectively to
help the plants
grow at its maximum
potential so these are different areas
in agriculture which are actively
upcoming and developing currently
and both in
basic mechanistic research and also in
application oriented research in
agriculture in plant biology
generally
and
neuroscience is also one of the field
where people have tried to understand or
people have tried to apply or mix data
analysis from samples from brain and
there is a practical difficulty in
acquiring samples
from brain from for live patients and
hence now
there is a lot of effort in trying to
relate to neuroscience and neuro
neurological disorder from samples from
blood or from sample samples from gut
microbiome etc so uh an advanced uh
analysis methods and data science
methods are helping us making these
making these connections that are
usually not observable using traditional
analysis methods and and
and evaluating them for the statistical
or statistical significance of these
connections and transcriptomic data
analysis as i mentioned is one of the
most
used omics data analysis or one of the
most applied omics data analysis to
variety and wide variety of different
questions related to
human translational biology and
neuroscience is not
agnostic to that also so traditionally
people take or people extract samples
once the patients have passed away from
the brain cells and compare it with the
healthy patients who are age-matched
gender-matched ethnicity matched so that
we are eliminating lot of other
confounding factors in trying to
understand the
gene expression landscape of
neurological
neuro neurological disorders compared to
healthy patients
so when we extend such analysis to
metabolic disorders like uh like um
like allergic reaction to gluten or like
allergic reaction to some specific uh
metabolome or some uh some people will
have acid reflux so in lot of these uh
these disorders and and and some people
will have difficulty in in um
in filtering cells in sydney so in lot
of these disorders again comics data
analysis is actually proving to be very
helpful because um traditional methods
of observing histological
data or
biochemical assay data is limited in
characterizing the tissue sample tissues
and samples
in what they offer and trying to extract
the genes and trying to extract the gene
expression data trying to extract the
dna from which in the within the cell is
um is actually more helpful in trying to
understand uh or trying to get a
holistic picture of the samples
themselves which can be
useful in
relating to various different
phenotypical applications and
phenotypical characteristics of these
samples that we have categorized like we
can take uh samples from healthy
patients compared to samples from who
has developed uh chronic allergy to for
example peanuts and we can understand uh
in what are the major ways the
transcript transcriptomics landscape
differ
in between these two samples
depending on where the samples are from
samples could be from um
from the skin or from the
from the stomach lining or from the gut
microbiome also so um so the
various other or mixed data types are
also explored in this um biological
approach
so
all biology is is not i mean
all biology is not related or limited to
being applied on earth
so upcoming research in space omics
where nasa and other space agencies from
all over the world are heavily
focused on heavily
investing is the application of omics
data analysis for understanding the
effect of space
on human body or on model systems so
people have found out effective method
to
simulate microgravity on modern systems
and microgravity on human cells
themselves so uh people observe or
people characterize these human cells uh
based on the omics data analysis or
molecular characterization that will
take multiple different omics data
characterization and then compare it
compare the data compare the
data landscape before and after
subjecting them subjecting the samples
or subjecting the model systems to
microgravity onto a space travel in
terms of uh in terms of astronauts or in
terms of even they took mouse to
international space station once to
perform these analysis so these are the
different
fields that uh biology and
bioinformatics and omics data big data
or mixed data analysis are actually
influencing actively and
and
very rapidly right i mean space omix is
kind of a field that nobody would have
heard about three years before and right
now uh it's actually picking up on even
a lot of upcoming and developing
countries are actually focused on
performing or understanding uh these uh
the effects of
microgravity and space travel on
astronauts and other
subjects
so we have
these yeah we have these different
fields that are being actively explored
on by students
as they have
as they have
presented you their research topic of
interest so it it depends upon what you
want to
focus on for example you can focus on
cystic fibrosis you can focus on
sars scope to
characterization uh using different
analysis method you can focus on
non-long long non-coding rnas for being
targets in leukemia and you can also
focus on different bioma trying to
understand biomarkers for prostate
cancer or cancer types that has not been
studied actively like cervical cancers
prostate cancer and etc so this doesn't
stop at
the
framework or at
different biological aspects that we are
limiting you to you can also map
trying to mix match these
analysis methods and different
biological questions that you can answer
from these so i
encourage you to look or explore this
page and this web page and web link has
a lot of information and
links forwarded for you to uh understand
the
effect of a research fellowship program
and its reach
through the aspects or through the
dimensions or through the view of uh
students themselves you can you are free
to check uh different submissions from
students and and
on the variety of topics that they were
interested in uh exploring
our mix data analysis and their
applications in general so with that
yeah we also have further more links to
uh some of the major or some of the key
talks from compiled from our
previous
webinars and from
symposium that we
successfully conducted at the end of or
at the beginning of april rather so with
that i passed the stage back to sri
gauri who will help you in filling out
the form and
and i think furthermore
is on the plate for the agenda thank you
very much for your
participation
all right thank you so much dr raghav so
we have a query
uh if you want to work on a project with
a new track which does not exist at your
platform how can we go about it how will
the program support us
uh rashi that's a that's a great
question you know that's an excellent
question so uh
i want to point out to you that the
research fellowship
program is intended to be three months
or six months program so if you want to
work on a track that is not a popular
one so you have to uh we have to find
for example approach this from a normal
project
point of view
um
if
you want to complete this in three
months then you have to make or we have
to approach this from either we perform
a study on a data set that is already
been studied well or we actually pick a
data set or pick a research question
that is not been studied or that is that
has a lot of potential to be explored
but we can still design a different
combinations and different uh
methodologies that will answer our key
questions that that is possible so this
the track or the pipeline or the
analysis methods that we are actually
proposing you or we are actually
presenting it to you
uh is like uh is like
building something from lego pieces like
what we are giving you is well formed or
well documented lego pieces then your
creativity is your limitation to
combine different analytical uh
different analysis methods and to
come up with a successful pipeline that
will answer your question so not only
here but also elsewhere
yes exactly so when you talk
specifically about synthetic biology and
application of bioinformatics here for
example application of bioinformatics
stays true to the well-established
methods no
if you want to develop methods then
then we have to uh we have to explore
further other opportunities in
developing methods but when we have a
different a myriad of different
methodologies and we are going to pick
the best one based on uh based on our
research
justification then that will form or
that will actually
answer your question or your focus right
we can choose the field to be synthetic
biology and we can use bioinformatics to
approach synthetic biology depending
upon the question that you want to
answer in that field so depending upon
the question we will
we will choose or we will decide on the
data set and depending upon the data set
we will actually decide on the uh
analysis methods so this is how it has
been uh it will be this is a framework
in which it will be applied to okay
so if
the analysis methods involve us uh for
example combining different pieces from
different
pipelines then we can easily do that
if it involves
for example uh developing a new
algorithm for mapping on the leads onto
the genome so why do we want to do that
we already have
seven or eight different uh
algorithm that has the same question
okay then we have a carrier question
yeah thank you
we have a carrier question why most
chemistry bioinformatics don't get job
on their own domain so it depends upon
the domain no you know i mean
bioinformatics is an application
oriented science and it's slowly
becoming and transforming into a science
and data science on its own so
bioinformatics when applied to domain
like cancer biology oncology becomes
more powerful rather than bioinformatics
as a standalone topic themselves
so that's that's why you will see many
people working on using bioinformatics
to answer key questions in the domain of
interest like cancer biology infectious
diseases like agriculture right
like chronic diseases diabetes
heart diseases right
lot of these translational application
oriented domain are the one which is
which is of focus and bioinformatics are
the skill based or methods based field
that is developing rapidly to
sustain on its own and also to
support these
data support these domains
for the translational applications
okay i think we should pass it on yes
i'll come back to this and let's pass
this on to sri giveaway it's been a
while and it's been it's been long time
and
let's finish up the require agenda for
today's meeting and then i will attend
to your query
all right so if you have any queries
please put them in the chat box so once
spash goes through the registration
process we will be attending to it so uh
now i'd like to pass on the stage to
sparsh
thank you so much dr
of uh for explaining uh each and every
research topic such
an extensive way manner and thank you
sri gauri so let me
share my screen
so hello everyone i am sparsh
and i am working as a business
development associate at find biotech so
i'll
quickly tell you about the registration
steps the steps to register for the
bioinformatics and data science research
fellowship program
okay now this is the program page and
when you scroll down
you will find the program overview what
actually the program is all about
now
when you scroll down more you will find
the whole framework about the research
fellowship program so as to complete
your
novel research project in a specified
tenure
okay for example introduction here we'll
be telling you about the overview of our
cloud tools of big data processing then
we'll give you uh an
overview about the introductory courses
on bioinformatics and computational
biology
then the second step is we'll be telling
you about how to evaluate uh for example
uh like research topic selection will be
there systematic literature review will
be there research proposal development
which will include project title project
description reference uh publication and
data sets which will uh which will you
be working on
then uh we'll be showing the practical
coursework and example projects on
different specialized tracks as uh dr
raghav just explained for example in
precision oncology in precision medicine
neurosciences agriculture and
bioinformatics etc
then uh
it's about the exploratory analysis of a
focus set of publicly available data set
to identify major trends and patterns
for investigation
then
uh
then the step is we'll be investigating
about the exploratory data analysis
we'll do the data driven research
hypothesis some statistical testing and
inference will be there
and in the end whatever you have done in
your training and in your analytical
part you will be uh writing down and
jotting down into a scientific
manuscript or a report writing
then following this we
i'll tell you about the resources and
the tenure
for which you can work on
so there are three different in yours
most probably four different in yours in
this
research fellowship program one is 45
days another is 60 days then it's 90
days and the fourth one is for six
months so there are some common
resources for all these tenure which are
you will have access to our omics logic
learn portal for the training and
learning part you will have access to
our t bioinfo server for the analysis
part then you will have access
to our coding sessions session
recordings then you'll have access to
our online mentor support
online technical support and after the
completion of the program you will be
you will get a certification
so these are the some of the common
resources for all the 10 years now what
the what's the difference between the
three is
in 45 days then uh program you will the
analysis will be of a intermediate level
of analysis and it won't be as like an
extensive one
for 60 and 90 days and now
90 days 10 years
other than
live sessions with the mentor other than
the weekly research fellowship meetings
you have an opportunity to fix a
one-on-one mentor sessions
then for the 90 days tenure with the
certificate of completion you will also
get a certificate of excellence and
again we have the one-on-one mentor uh
mentor opportunity in this particular
tenure also
so there if you scroll above you'll find
a drop down menu and from here you can
particularly select
in uh depending upon your location so
right now i think it's not working for
me but depending upon your location you
can select
uh in which for example if you are
living in uh us so you will get the
amount in usd if you are living in uh
nigeria then you will get to uh then you
will get the amount in naira if you are
living in india then you will get the
amount in inr so right now it is like
the amount is set for uh us candidates
and uh for 45 days the amount is dollar
350. for 60 days it's dollar 450 usd and
for 90 days it's dollar 550 the amount
varies per location
and we do have scholarships for
scholarships you can mail us at
marketing at the right omixlogic.com
and we'll be further discussing and
we'll be further discussing with our
internal team how much scholarship we
can provide and avail you for but we do
provide scholarship up to 50 percent
so uh after this i'll be sharing the
scholarship form
and if you have further queries you can
mail
mail us at marketing at omixlogic.com or
you can contact us on
uh i'll share the contact information in
the chat box itself the uh the number is
active on whatsapp also so if you have
any doubts regarding the registration
step the fee structure or the resources
please put your question in the chat box
thank you so much over to you sugary
all right thank you so much sparsh so uh
there was a ques query that we have
missed that is uh sonia had asked is it
is the tbr info platform freely
accessible to do analysis
is asking is the t by info platform
freely accessible